david dobrik okay first of all some big
news for you ten million subscribers
yeah I'm sorry that's pretty epic and
you've had just a lot of really big hits
lately you know the hits just keep on
coming on David's blog I mean a lot of
celebrity cameos everyone especially
loved the recent Courtney Cox surprise
our queen Susie yes Susie's a huge fan
of friends like she has she has a French
she's a French sure she's two French
shirts and like a big French poster in
her room and all she talks about his
friends so I think Jason and Trisha I
ran into Coco Courtney Cox's daughter
and then we can just connect the pieces
Oh Suzy loves friends and Jason knows
Coco who obviously knows her mother and
then yeah we put that together and the
day that we surprise her with Courtney
Cox she was wearing a French shirt
completely by coincidence because the
night before she went on the Friends
tour which is crazy so she was like
that's all she was talking about in the
car was the French tour that she just
went on at Warner Brothers so it was
like meant to be and then we showed up
at Courtney Cox's house it was perfect
and how cool is Courtney in the vlog
great everyone's always so nice I'm
never disappointed which kind of bums me
out I have to find someone that sucks
the according to no that year 420 log
like parodies the friends and show
dishes
my buddy wore my merch to it that
completely copied the friends logo so I
was scared that maybe she was gonna
relay that to the friends team you know
we're gonna get sued but I don't know no
I don't think she did she I don't think
she had any idea what I was doing I
think her daughter was just nice enough
to be like mom you got to do this Suzy's
still kind of reeling from meeting
Monica yeah not only that but we took
her to New York for the first time and
she still texts me about stuff like that
she's like that entire family's so
grateful when they get anything because
they're not used to getting cool gifts
so when they get anything cool they're
just like this is the best thing ever so
they're there she's really pumped yeah